SOWMYA KANNAN: Hey there.
Welcome to Cloud OnAir, live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting webinars
every Tuesdays this march.
I'm Sowmya Kanna.
I'm a technical curriculum
developer in the Google Cloud
Platform training team,
and this is my cohost.
MYLENE BIDDLE:
I'm Mylene Biddle,
and I'm also a technical
curriculum developer for GCP.
SOWMYA KANNAN: Brian Rice,
our technical curriculum lead,
has graciously volunteered
to be our Q&A moderator.
We want to answer
as many questions
as we can, so leave your
questions on the webinar
platform.
We'll answer a lot of them live.
And if we run out
of time, we'll make
sure to type all the
responses to the ones
that we don't get
a chance to cover.
MYLENE BIDDLE: Thank you Brian.
SOWMYA KANNAN:
Today's webinar is all
about learning how
Stackdriver features--
Webinar is all about learning
how Stackdriver features enable
you to debug, monitor,
trace, and enable
logging in your applications
that are running
on Google Kubernetes Engine.
This webinar will be relevant
for cloud professionals
building cloud-native
applications on Google Cloud
Platform.
If you enjoy today's
webinar, definitely
check out the
Developing Applications
with Google Cloud Platform
specialization on Coursera.
At the end of the webinar
you'll receive a voucher
to get started with the
courses and the specialization.
If you want to learn more
about the training that we have
to offer, check out
cloud.google.com/training.
All right, let's see what we
have in store for you today.
We'll be talking about
cloud-native applications
and microservices.
We'll look at a couple
of customer case studies.
And Mylene here has lined up
a couple of neat demos for us
about microservices
and Stackdriver.
We'll wrap up with some Q&A.
Microservices seem to be the
rage in software engineering
today, and rightly so.
Traditionally, monolithic
applications were the norm.
And with monolithic
applications,
the problem is that the codebase
becomes bloated over time.
It can be difficult to determine
where code needs to be changed,
and packages can have
tangled dependencies.
The entire application needs
to be deployed and tested
even if a change is made to a
small part of the application.
This increases the
effort and the risk
that you have to take when
you're making feature changes
and bug fixes.
Microservices, on
the other hand,
enable you to structure
your application components
to match business boundaries.
The code base for each
service is modular.
Each service can be updated
and deployed independently
without requiring your customers
to change at the same time.
Each service can be
scaled independently
depending on load.
For each microservice, teams
can use different programming
languages and tool kits that
work best for the problem
that they are trying to solve.
Well-designed microservices
are loosely coupled at runtime.
Tightly coupled components
can make an application
less resilient to failures,
spikes in traffic, and changes
to services.
And intermediate components
such as a message queue
can be used to implement
loose coupling,
perform asynchronous
processing, and buffer messages
in case of spikes in traffic.
You can use a Cloud Pub/Sub
topic as a message queue.
Publishers can publish
messages to the topic
and subscribers can subscribe
to messages from the topic.
In the example
that you see here,
the order service can
continue to publish messages
to the message queue even if
the inventory service is down.
And later when the inventory
service comes back online,
it can retrieve all orders
from the message queue,
including the ones that came
in when the service was down.
That's pretty cool.
Mylene, why don't you tell us
about the microservices demo
that you have lined up for us?
MYLENE BIDDLE:
Sure thing, Sowmya.
So the microservices demo is
a cross-platform application
that demonstrates microservice
best practices, some
of them described by Sowmya.
The architecture of the demo
microservices application
was intentionally designed to
provide as many microservices
as possible.
It was also written in
multiple languages--
Java, .NET Core,
Go, and Node.js--
as she mentioned so that
different parts of the team
can really write the
code and the microservice
based on the problem
they're trying to solve.
And it also exercises a number
of different technologies.
As you see in the
architecture diagram,
the microservices are roughly
defined by the functions
of an e-commerce site.
The demo I'm going to show
you uses a fake web store
application called
The Sock Shop,
and it runs on Google
Kubernetes Engine.
Before exploring what it
takes to debug and monitor
the application, we're going
to explore the application.
In order to do that, I'm going
to switch over to the console.
And in the console--
let me just get my
mouse over here.
I'm going to go to
Kubernetes Engine.
You can see here when we
go to Kubernetes Engine
that my sock shop cluster
has been deployed.
When I navigate to discovery
and load balancing,
we're going to see about 14
separate microservices that
have been deployed as
part of this cluster.
SOWMYA KANNAN:
That's pretty neat.
So over a dozen
micro services have
to play well together in order
for this demo to work well.
MYLENE BIDDLE: Absolutely.
And again, like we showed
you in the diagram,
they're all written in
different languages.
So you could have
one team working
on one piece and
another with the other,
and they all seamlessly
work together.
To get to the
web-page front end,
I'm going to click
here on this endpoint,
and here we have our sock shop.
So I'm going to generate some
order points and some areas
that I know exist so that we
can really figure out what's
going on with this application.
So I'm going to go
in here, and I'm
going to add these
crossed socks.
I'm going to look in my cart.
And so here we see there is
one pair of crossed socks.
So let's say I had a
customer report that when
they added something to the cart
and then updated the quantity
to zero and then clicked
Update Basket that it
updated the quantity, but it
still kept it in the cart.
So obviously that's an error.
We generated an error.
So I'll remove that, and
we'll look into that later.
And now I'm just going to
add some more data points.
I am going to add to the cart.
I'm going to go
back into my cart.
I'm going to log in so that
I can complete an order.
SOWMYA KANNAN:
It's funny there's
a market for holy socks.
MYLENE BIDDLE: You never know.
So if I go back in here--
You never know.
So if I go back
in here, I'm going
to click Proceed to Checkout.
And I've now created one order.
So I'm going to
go back into here,
and I'm going to add a
couple more socks so we
have a couple more data points.
And as that refreshes, I'll go
in here, proceed to checkout.
And I'm going to add
one more pair of socks.
I actually had a
customer report that when
they add the
colorful to the cart
that it takes longer
than the others.
As you can see, there seems to
be some latency around that.
So that's something that maybe
we should look into later.
So I'll go ahead and
click back into the cart,
proceed to checkout.
And now we have
three separate orders
that we can look
into in Stackdriver.
So with that, I will
hand it back to Sowmya.
There we go.
SOWMYA KANNAN: Nice.
So you're probably sold on
the benefits of microservices.
You've been listening to the
buzz in the industry today.
Microservices have
many advantages,
but they bring a new set
of challenges related
to complexity, communication
between services, latency,
and debugging.
Debugging, logging, and
monitoring a distributed
application can seem
pretty daunting.
Stackdriver helps provide
greater visibility
and increase
application reliability.
You can monitor GCP and
multicloud environments,
identify trends
and prevent issues,
reduce monitoring overhead,
and fix problems faster.
Stackdriver improves
signal-to-noise ratio.
Remember, you want to wake
up your on-call support folks
for real emergencies only.
You really don't want
to be in a situation
where you find out from your
customers on social media
that your application is down.
It's important to monitor the
status of your application
and services to ensure
that they are always
available and
performing optimally.
The monitoring data can be
used to automatically alert
operations teams as soon as
the system begins to fail.
Operations teams can then
diagnose and address the issue
promptly, ideally before
your customers even realize
that the application is down.
Implement a health-check
endpoint for each service.
The [INAUDIBLE] handler
should check the health
of all dependencies
and infrastructure
components required for the
service to function properly.
For example, the endpoint
handler that you see here
can check the performance
and availability
of storage, database,
and network connections
required by the service.
The endpoint handler should
return an HTTP response
code of 200 for
successful health checks.
And if the health check
fails, the endpoint handler
can return a response code of
503 or a more specific response
code, depending on the error.
A health-monitoring agent
such as a load balancer
or Stackdriver Monitoring can
periodically send requests
to a health-check endpoint.
Load balancers use health checks
to determine if an application
instance is healthy and is
capable of receiving traffic.
If the health check fails
beyond the threshold
that you have defined,
Stackdriver Monitoring
can send you an
alert automatically.
Treat your logs
as event streams.
That's another
best practice here.
Logs constitute a
continuous stream
of events that keep occurring
as long as your application is
running.
Don't manage log files
in your application.
That can get really
clunky really fast.
Instead, write to an event
stream such as standard
out and let the underlying
infrastructure collate
all events for later
analysis and storage.
With this approach, you can
set up logs-based metrics
and trace requests across
services in your application.
With Google Stackdriver, you
can debug your application,
set up error reporting, set up
logging and logs-based metrics,
trace requests across
services, and monitor
applications running in
a multicloud environment.
All right, here's a
customer case study.
A builder [INAUDIBLE]
develops cloud-based software
and mobile apps for
construction professionals.
They have tools for managing
presales, projects, customers,
and financials.
Frustrated by frequently
slow performance,
builder [INAUDIBLE]
switched from a shared cloud
infrastructure to
Google Cloud Platform.
The company now delivers
more-reliable performance
to customers.
Stackdriver Monitoring
is a key component
of their application along
with Google BigQuery and Google
Compute Engine.
MYLENE BIDDLE: Great to hear
of a customer who went all in
and how it's helping them.
SOWMYA KANNAN: Uber site
reliability engineer Ryan
Shatford explained how
they use Stackdriver
for monitoring dashboards and
policy-based alert management.
Uber quickly created dashboards
to visualize monitoring data
for compute instances
and for VPN statistics.
Mylene, I'd love to see
your demo about Stackdriver
monitoring, logging, and trace.
MYLENE BIDDLE: Absolutely.
So like Sowmya mentioned,
Stackdriver Trace
is a key tool that helps
you understand latency
in your applications by showing
you how long actual customer
requests are taking through
every step of the journey
through a distributed system.
There's a traffic generator
included in the project
that we actually give
you a link to on GitHub,
and it's sending traffic
to our application, which
is sufficient for
Trace to provide more
information about the latency.
So let me go ahead and
switch back to the console.
There we go.
I'm going to go
back to the console.
And I am now going to
navigate to Stackdriver Trace.
SOWMYA KANNAN:
Hey, look at that.
This application has a
health-check endpoint
implemented, and you
can see the screen here
that Stackdriver is
doing a health check
every couple of minutes or
so and receiving data back.
Pretty neat.
MYLENE BIDDLE: Pretty cool.
So I'm going to switch
to the trace list.
And so here in the trace
list we have some information
about the spans.
So each span
represents, what are
the steps that was completed
during the processing
of a request?
So I'm going to filter
it because there
is a lot of information,
and I'm just
going to look at the orders.
And if you recall, we
made a couple of orders.
If we click here
on the span, we're
going to get more
information about what
was happening in each step.
If we scroll down and
look at the timeline,
we get more information
about the steps
of the requests that are
happening both in parallel
and sequentially.
SOWMYA KANNAN: So that's
really nice, right?
So you can visualize
which of your calls
are happening in a
serial manner and which
are happening in parallel
and even identify
areas of optimization.
So if you see that there's
a bunch of calls happening
serially which you could
instead do in parallel,
then that would reduce
the amount of time
that it takes for you
to complete request.
So really great
insight into what's
happening under the hood
with your application.
MYLENE BIDDLE: Yeah,
it really gives you
a good overall
picture from a lot
of data points of
what's happening
in a timeline-based view
in your application.
So now that we've looked a
little bit into the trace,
I'm going to go over to
Stackdriver Error Reporting
and look into that error that
we tried to replicate that,
let's say, a customer
told us they encountered.
So when we navigate
to Error Reporting,
the first thing we
see is an error.
And for transparency,
I did generate
the error a couple of times
before we started this demo,
but we did generate
it once here.
So when we click into
the error details,
it's going to show you how
many times this happened.
So obviously if you
were replicating
something a customer saw
you could say, OK, well
I did it once.
The customer saw it 15 times.
We need to fix this.
It tells you the
first time it was seen
and then the last time it
was seen, super helpful.
So this is the one I
generated just now.
We have a couple
more details up here.
If you click on
the Overflow menu,
it gives you the option to turn
on notifications for the error
group.
That's really useful
so that you can always
monitor what's going on,
and it's one click away.
You also have a
resolution status.
With the resolution
status you can go in here
and for this error group you
can say, I've acknowledged it.
Our team's working on it.
You can say it's resolved.
If you resolve an error group
and then it crops up again,
you didn't really fix it,
then you will automatically
be notified that the error
group you previously resolved
has now been reopened.
So now that we have that, we
have a couple more details.
If you look down
here in the errors
and you want to see
exactly what was happening
at the time of the error, I
can click here on View Logs,
and it's going to navigate
me to Stackdriver Logging.
And it's going to
filter down to the time
when that error happened.
A lot of things are
happening though,
so this isn't super
easy to parse through.
So I'm going to filter to
just the errors, because it's
showing me all of the
logs of everything
that happened for all
of the microservices.
And as we saw, there's
a handful, two handfuls.
So here is our error.
If I expand it and then
I look at the labels,
it gives me lots of
information about the error.
And it's actually telling me
that the error happened right
here in this front-end pod.
If I click here and I look
at Show Matching Entries,
it's then going to go to the
advanced filter for logging
where it's showing me
all of the errors that
happened for that specific pod.
Now I also want to
see what happened
before and after the
error for this pod.
And since this detailed
filter has already
been filled out
for me, I'm going
to remove the severity of
error, resubmit the filter.
And now I can see,
here's my error.
Here is what happened exactly
before the error and then
what happened after it.
SOWMYA KANNAN:
That's pretty cool.
So you don't have to
wade through log files.
Instead, you're able to quickly
zone in on the problem area
and try to understand what's
going on with your application.
MYLENE BIDDLE: Absolutely.
It's very powerful
to do it this way.
So now that we have some
context around what's wrong,
let's go back to that error.
And so we're going to dive into
the problem a little bit more
by looking at snapshots.
A snapshot captures the
local variables and call
stack at a specific line
location in your source code.
So when we look at
the error details,
you'll see that it
actually tells you
the exact line of code where
this broke, right here.
It's in the index.js
file at line 165.
So if I click here, it
is going to redirect me
to Stackdriver Debug.
We'll wait for that to load.